Vous vous souvenez ,dans la vidéos sur l'épilépsie et les jeux vidéos ?
Je vous avais dit que l'on allais reparler de la PLS.
Bah voilà ,c'est aujourd'hui !
Doug Ross , Cécilia ? ,Dr House ,Michaela Quinn, Derek Shepherd ,Elliot Reid ...
ça vous fait une bonne raison d'apprendre à sauver des vies !
L'autre raison c'est que d'apprendre à sauver des vies...ça peut sauver des vies !
La PLS ,c'est pas une technique d'humiliation, c'est la ...
Position Latéral de Sécuritée
C'est la position dans laquelle ont doit placer quelqu'un qui réspire mais qui est inconscient
Pour éviter qu'il s'étouffe avec sa langue , par exemple...
Ou avec son vomis ...
...ou avec un petit animal qui viendrais creuser son terrier dans l'arrière gorge de la victime...
En réalité ,on avale pas sa langue comme on l'entend dire souvent .
Quand une personne est inconsciente tous ses muscles se relachent et si elle est allongée sur le dos
...la langue tombe en arrière et vien bouchée les vois respiratoires .
Le problème c'est que quand une victime est inconsciente ,elle perd un certain nombre de réflexe comme celui...
Donc il faut le faire à sa place pour lui sauver la vie ...
Bon se sera quand même plus parlant avec une petite démonstration !
Mais pour ça il va me falloir un mannequin de secourisme
Nan ,naaan, attend ...Mannequin...Pas genre Adrianna Karembeu...
Mannequin genre...mannequin de secourisme...
Ummmh !...
Mais attend ...Il est à poil là !Hein !
Exact !...
Moi je peut garder ,quand même, mon slip et mes jambes ?...
Aller d'accord !
File !
Cette personne est inconsciente !
Je suis totalement inconscient !
Alors qu'es que je peut faire ?
La première chose à faire c'est de...
Et est pas juste entrain de faire une petite sieste ...
Pour ça ,adresser vous directement à elle et donner lui un ordre simple .
Monsieur !Vous m'entendez ?Ouvrez les yeux !Serrez-moi la main
Si vous n'obtenez aucune réponse la victime est bien inconsciente
Et il faut prévenir les secours...
Demander à quelqu'un de faire le 15 ,pour joindre le SAMU ou le 18 ,pour joindre les pompiers
De toutes façon ils comunniquent entre eux et ils vous enveront l'équipe la plus adapter à la situation !
Si vous êtes tout seul , appelez à l'aide en commencant à vous occupé de la victime
A l'aide en commencant à vous occuper de la victime...
A l'aide !
Ensuite ,occupez-vous de tous se qui pourrai géner la respiration
Enlever les premiers boutons du pantalon , desserrer la ceinture ,ect..
Bo !Oh ! Tu laisse ça ! Je respire très bien avec !
Avec la paume de votre main ,appuyer sur le front et glisser 2 ou 3 doigts de l'autre main sous le menton, basculer délicatement la tête en arrière.
La langue se décolle et libère les vois aèriennes ,mais il faut vérifier qu'il ni a rien d'autre qui les bloquent.
Ouvrez la bouche de la victime et retirer les corps étrangers qu'il y a à l'intérieur .
Pareil pour les prothèses dentaires si elles se sont décrochées.
Si la victime porte des lunettes retiré lui et ...
Puis son avant bras ,également à angle droit la paume de la main vers le ciel
~La direction vous informes que la fessée n'es pas obligatoire pour la PLS~
Ouvrez la bouche de la victime sans bouger sa tête,Voila ! Elle est instalée dans une position stable qui lui permet de respirée et dévacuée les liquides qu'elles a dans la bouche.
Et sa colonne vertébral est toujours bien rester dans l'axe ,donc ,pas de risque d'avoir abimmée sa moelle épiniaire
...Jusqu'à l'arriver des secours
D'ailleurs ,si personne ne les à prévenue ...c'est le moment
Merci Julien !Tu m'as sauver !
Bah...!Aller!C'est bien peu de chose tien !...Par contre...euhh...
...J'aime beaucoup ton slip ! ...
Nan ! Ni pense même pas !
Voila !DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui ! On se retrouve très vite pour un nouveaux geste qui sauve!
Abonnez-vous pour pas rater ça !En attendant evitez les ennuis ,prenez soin de vous et des autres .Et portez-vous bien !
-Sous-Titre :Johane Martins .-2017